if there's something kids like to do
it's demolition and that gave me the
idea to try Lego RC car demolition
derbys the basic idea is to take any
inexpensive RC car that you can get at
Target Walmart wherever take something
like two sided tape or 3m command and
stick it on all of these surfaces of the
RC car then take your classic flat Lego
plates and mount them on all of the
surfaces that you know a car might be
able to run into another car with at
that point you can start your game each
player gets a number of LEGO bricks
probably 2025 per person and it's a good
idea that each person gets different
colored bricks the kids have a minute to
put the bricks all over the car and then
you have a demolition derby set the kids
to just ramming into each other with
their cars over and over again trying to
knock off the bricks maybe at the end of
few minutes everybody stops and
whoever's got the most bricks left on
the car wins the match one important
thing to remember when using these style
of RC cars is the remotes work on two
different common radio frequencies 27
megahertz or 49 megahertz so if you want
to have good car on car carnage you have
to pick up cars that run on the two
different frequencies so the remotes
won't interfere with each other so it's
a really easy project to put together
quickly and have a great time with